[Musique]
bonjour content de vous retrouver pour
dimension politique à une semaine du
premier tour de la primaire de la gauche
nous allons contribuer à ce débat
une primaire unique dans la vème
république puisque le ps seul est imposé
après cinq ans de pouvoir sept candidats
vous le voyez candidates en lice manuel
valls arnaud montebourg benoît hamon
sylvia pinel françois de rugy et jean
luc bennahmias et vincent peillon et
trois candidats socialistes ont
représenté sur ce plateau
bonjour philippe baumel bonjour vous
êtes député de saône-et-loire très
proche d'arnaud montebourg on me le
direz vous faites partie de son équipe
de campagne
bonjour michel neugnot bon je vous êtes
le premier vice président du conseil
régional vous dirigez en côte d'or la
campagne de manuel valls
l'ancien premier ministre dans cette
primaire et on doit rajouter on vous
remercie parce que vous remplacer au
pied levé laurent grandguillaume fauché
par la grippe et pierre grand c'est
bonjour jour vous êtes conseiller
régional vous avez choisi de soutenir
benoît hamon dans cette primaire dinia
long que vous n'appartenez pas un parti
politique ce qui n'est pas forcément
fréquents dans cette primaire de la
gauche
rajoutons que comme pour la primaire de
droite nous avions souhaité quatre
candidats sur ce plateau
nous avons proposé au soutien de vincent
peillon de participer à ce débat mais
aucun élu de la région n'a accepté un
débat diffusé en simultané sur facebook
sur la page de france 3 bourgogne où
vous pouvez intervenir et commenté même
chose sur twitter avec le hashtag dit
mme paul bourgogne je le disais pour
commenter c'est une première dans la
vème république un parti qui s'impose
une primaire après cinq ans de pouvoir
alors on parle de primaires de
désignation mais philippe baumel
certains parlent aussi primaire de
destitution est ce que c'est ce qui
s'est passé finalement le président ne
se représente pas cette primaire la
destituer je ne crois pas parce que les
décisions de retrait du président la
république a été prise avant que
s'enclenche le processus des primaires
et le président lui donne d'ailleurs
avait accepté la logique donc je pense
que tout ça ne t'a pas grand chose à
voir
je rappelle en plus que c'est certes la
circonstance était est unique mais c'est
la deuxième fois nous que nous
organisons une primaire et c'est même le
à gauche que l'on a inventé la primaire
donc je pense que en vérité bis bis
repetita placent end une certaine façon
est qu en vérité on est dans un
processus mais dans bien installés dont
arnaud montebourg a été d'ailleurs
l'initiateur enfin en même temps c'est
quand même une façon oblige
le président qui a exercé le pouvoir
cinq ans à venir de la remettre son
titre en jeu mais c'est une évolution
aussi que nous avons tous voulu je crois
de surtout les bains ici rassemblés
c'est une cinquième république qui doit
sortir aussi d'une vision un petit peu
messianique du président la république
et au moins donner bien il faut pouvoir
vérifier s'il est en adéquation avec sa
propre famille politique et avec
l'opinion publique nous sommes au niveau
des six nations
moi je pense que il ya eu pendant la
période qui a préparé ces primaires un
certain nombre d' attaques systématiques
contre le président de la république qui
s'est trouvée de ce fait dans une
situation où il a apprécié qu'il n'était
pas en capacité des candidats
je crois que le fait regrettable pour
moi il est nécessaire quand on veut être
candidat à la présidence de la
république et qu'on sort d'une mandature
de cinq ans de répondre à trois critères
le premier critère c'est d'être fier de
ce que l'on a fait même si tout n'a pas
été parfait
le deuxième critère qui est nécessaire
c'est de penser que la victoire est
possible est possible en 2017 et non pas
en 2022
ils vont revenir et le troisième critère
c'est d'être en capacité de rassembler
et maintenant des primaires doivent
répondre à ce troisième critère monde en
perspective de rassembler pour gagner on
va développer sa national ne veut pas
simplement des maisons très optimiste
sur le rassemblement
pierre grosser certaines questions pour
commencer effectivement vu du camp de
benoît hamon est ce que il y avait la
volonté d'une femme manière de le
sanctionner le président de la
république je n'ai pas envie de parler
de sanctionner j'aurais parlé que du
fait des primaires comme un esprit
d'ouverture c'est l'ouverture vers une
nouvelle forme de gouvernance et ça a
été rappelé et a déjà eu une primaire
c'est la ligne droite on continue en a
ouvert avec une première primaire
on continue s'il n'y avait pas eu de
primaire c'était quelque part un peu en
se renfermer sur soi même est hélas
aujourd'hui cette primaire est un signe
d'ouverture
c'est un signe qui permet effectivement
les changes la confrontation d'idées
pour aller pour progresser et je crois
que michel neugnot parle de
rassemblement et moi je parlerais de
aussi de progression d'aller un peu plus
loin à gauche pour faire valoir nos
idées on va entrer sur le ce qui nous
différencie
oui parce que pour se rassembler moi je
crois d'abord il faut savoir sur quoi se
rassembler et qui est sûr qu'elle corpus
d'idées sur quels types de projets en
bonnet et parfois aussi fait l'analyse
du bilan procéder à un droit
d'inventaire sur ce qui a été fait ce
qui a été mal fait ou ce qui n'a pas
essayé de faire du tout donc je pense
que c'est les prix d'un c'est salutaire
alors vous nous amener à la partie
suivante
après cette introduction effectivement
dans la primaire chaque candidat va dire
énumère ses propositions aurait
peut-être évité de faire un catalogue
parce qu'on sait bien que les
propositions elles sont faites aussi
pour construire une image pour placer le
candidat on va dire sur l'échiquier sur
l'échiquier politique
est-ce qu'en ce moment ce certains
parlent de catalogue de mesures pour
essayer de récupérer des électeurs est
ce que c'est ça qui se passe un petit
peu pierre grosser et et je vous je vous
pose la question parce que benoît hamon
à un nombre de mesures très à gauche on
parle beaucoup du revenu minimum mais il
n'ya pas que ça les deux suicides par
exemple la gpa qu'on trouve chez
d'autres mais il ya beaucoup de mesures
comme ça est ce que le but c'est
d'essayer de récupérer de rassembler le
plus d'électeurs de la primaire
effectivement d'abord le but est
toujours de rats souris mais le plus
délicat avec l'idée qu'on fait dès
l'imposition sans forcément en sachant
qu'on pourra peut-être pas les appliquer
le but avant tout d'essayer de
convaincre et d'amener un nouvel esprit
je crois que un nouvel esprit ou un
esprit nouveau et je crois que benoît
hamon a montré déjà par son engagement
ne serait ce que par rapport à
l'économie sociale et solidaire c'est
quelque chose dont personne ne parle il
la loi a permis de développer l'économie
sociale et solidaire je suis moi même
issu de cette société civile en étant
dirigeants d'une scop et qui travaille
sur l'insertion de personnes en
difficulté on va dire pour les bons
l'union qui vous connaissent moins que
vous avez vous travaillé que benoît
hamon sur l'économie sociale et
solidaire
c'est une loi qui permet effectivement
de considérer au delà de l'économie
sociale de considérer un autre type
d'économie et notre type aujourd'hui de
production etc l'ensemble des mesures le
benoît mans est toujours un peu accès
par rapport à cette différence qui est
toujours lié à se dire demain qu'est la
politique de choix on pourra revenir sur
le revenu universel etc
mais à chaque fois c'est de se dire
ouvrons ouvrons des portes ouvrant les
portes et après on verra mais commençons
par dire que les choses ne sont pas
possibles avec benoît c'est vraiment le
champ des possibles qu'on a envie
d'explorer alors on a positionné benoît
hamon sur l'échiquier
philippe baumel si je vous dis arnaud
bons mots arnaud montebourg il essaie de
développer un récit autour de l'identité
au syli national de l'interventionnisme
économique une forme d'euroscepticisme
sais je suis bien je suis bien bien posé
en disant ça je refuserais qu'ont
compris une partie du message oui en
effet je pense que montebourg y c'est
d'être cohérent avec ce qu'il a toujours
défendues depuis une quinzaine d'années
avec une vision sur le made in france
qui garde tout à fait identifié par
rapport à ce qu'il a fait lui aussi
lorsqu'il était au gouvernement ce qu'il
avait même défendu avant il ya aussi
toutes les thématiques liées aux
institutions la 6ème république à la
volonté de rénover en profondeur le
système politique pour faire en sorte
que l'abstention diminue que les
français se sentent plus représentés
c'est moi je siège au sein d'une
assemblée nationale ou en finalement une
âme il ya à peine 60% des français qui
sont représentés donc c'est une c'est un
système qui dysfonctionne donc voilà il
essaie d'être cohérent et de faire des
propositions et puis des propositions
concrètes pour tous les français c'est à
dire il veut être le candidat par
exemple de la feuille de paie et c'est
pour ça que il propose une baisse
significative de la csg qui permet
finalement pour tous ceux qui gagnent en
dessous de 2000 euros d'avoir une 13e -
voilà c'est du concret manuel valls qui
lui a exercé le pouvoir presque jusqu'au
bout on ne situerait comment manuel
valls est est ce que c'est on pourra
nous dire on a dit michel gognau de
l'autre côté de la table par rapport il
n'y a que les femmes servent presque 7
de gauche voilà l'esprit de la question
c'est est-ce que c'est de gauche est ce
que manuel valls est vraiment une autre
gauche sur l'image qu'ils essaient de
donner un 10 en opposant par exemple
travail phare nien sécurité c'est la
gauche qui a exercé le pouvoir et qui
veut continuer d'exercer le pouvoir
c'est la gauche qui connaît les limites
que l'on a et la difficulté qu'il ya
dans un monde qui est en pleine mutation
de proposer uniquement un ensemble de
petites mesures sans montrer l'objectif
ce qui ce qui a péché dans le précédent
quinquennat
ce que n'a pas vous parler dit en train
de se terminer cet emprunt ce terme
l'actuel parce que ce qui a péché c'est
que je n'ai pas eu un discours de vérité
sur la situation de la france comme tous
sommes arrivés et d'autre part moi je
suis contre le fait de proposer des
mesures et d'exercer tout le débat sur
les mesures présentées en a une
ce qui compte c'est la cohérence du
projet c'est la cohérence du projet et
le projet porté par manuel valls est un
projet qui vise à la fois la république
faure qui est nécessaire et puis une
france plus juste
ce sont les deux piliers sur lequel il
faut avancer et partir en mettant en
avant telle ou telle injure comme étant
l'alpha et l'oméga de ce que l'on doit
faire
à mon avis amène des déceptions au bout
du compte c'est vrai que des déceptions
indiana et on parle beaucoup de
cohérence
on pourrait parler aussi des
incohérences mais cette fois ci du bilan
cantona est promu
des fractures majeur au sein de la
gauche comme la loi travail
et comme la déchéance de nationalité des
débats sincèrement qu'on aurait pu mener
tout à fait différemment qui aurait pu
donner lieu à des arbitrages consensuel
parce que dans la loi travail par
exemple il ya des aspects que je
considère qu'on positif et j'ai pourtant
été amenés en tant que parlementaires à
ne pas la voter
par manque de débat et à par application
d'un 49,3 absurde qui ne correspond plus
du tout à la tante de cocon la majorité
des français du fonctionnement de la
république dont tout ça c'est
l'incohérence du bilan avec un discours
sucré que j'entends encore ce matin et
qui malheureusement reflète par certains
aspects un bilan dont nous espérions ne
pas nous charger de france a voulu
rebondir sur rebondir à la fois sur la
loi travail mais aussi sur se dire que
je partage en disant qu'il faut qu'on
ait un projet plus juste et surtout un
projet plus démocratique qui prend plus
en compte les desiderata qui prend plus
en compte la société civile qui prend
plus en compte les syndicats qui prend
plus en compte un certain nombre
d'acteurs de la société plus
démocratique on va parler effectivement
de de la proportionnelle on pourrait
parler aussi de mesures comme je vais
pas revenir dessus sur le revenu
universel parce que quelque part ça
ouvre le choix je reviens toujours là
dessus parce que ça me paraît important
et aujourd'hui ce qu'on a besoin c'est
de se dire qu'on a besoin d'une économie
qui ce qu'ils aillent en avant qu'il
soit plus volontaires et qu'ils arrêtent
de mettre des freins parce que ça ne
peut pas marcher et je crois que les
choses il faut se dire ça est ce que je
pourrais reprocher avant au gouvernement
en place c'est cette politique en terme
de deux freins de se dire c'est pas
possible c'est un manqué d'audace
quelque part on entend beaucoup de
propositions dans tous les camps à peu
de choses près et en même temps on a
l'impression que ces propositions
arrivent maintenant alors que le parti
socialiste est au pouvoir depuis cinq
ans qu'il a surtout été au pouvoir dans
les collectivités locales régionales
depuis très longtemps et beaucoup
d'observateurs font remarquer que le
logiciel à idées du ps n'a pas beaucoup
bougé de
puis une douzaine d'années il ya un
paradoxe entre pas grand chose de
nouveau et puis tout qui sort maintenant
c'est quoi c'est un but d'affichage
c'est une volonté de voir plus loin
c'est quoi d'abord parce que je crois
qu'il est difficile pour un parti au
pouvoir dans toutes les circonstances
des déjà vécu des périodes similaires
il est évident est difficile de remettre
sans arrêt en cause de l'action du
gouvernement au moment et de nourrir en
parallèle un débat dans le parti sur
notre logiciel vous étiez dans
l'opposition vous n'avez pas non plus
inventé grand chose au parti socialiste
qu'est-ce qui a été nous qu'est ce qui
était révolutionnaire et des tous les
débats qui ont eu lieu
je me souviens présente du travail qui a
été orchestrée par martine aubry avant
2012 et qui a permet de développer un
projet qui a été repris pour l'essentiel
d'ailleurs par le candidat à la
présidentielle françois hollande etc a
permis de convaincre les français de sur
notre projet de société secerno s'il y
en avait eu neuf avions eu aucune
différence avec la gestion sarkozy je
pense que les français ne n'aurais pas
chercher de ce côté là l'adie fait de la
différence c'est que le travail de
projets de travail d'idées il avait été
fait par le parti socialiste la
difficulté c'est que en gros depuis que
le puck depuis que martine aubry a
quitté la rue de solférino le parti et
s'est mis en panne d'une certaine façon
et à ce moment là on n'a pas pu nourrir
un logiciel partager et chacun est parti
dans son écurie construire son projet
certaine si sombre et des désagréments
certains s'y sont pris très tôt
incestueux et âgées de façon de vous
répondre
parfois certains s'y sont pris à 15
jours c'est vrai que c'est surprenant
mais et parfois reprennent les idées des
autres d'ailleurs mais ils ne sont pas
représentés autour cette table ici donc
j'ai du mal de vincent peillon vincent
peillon et le ronron on se pose de tous
la question de savoir qui a passé deux
fameux coup de fil à neuchâtel pour pour
filles est livré avec 100 payons cette
idée dans une raison c'est y répondre
exit donc je pense que vous avez une
vague idée howie m'a fait je ne sais pas
si elle est assise c'est la bonne donc
je la soumettrai pas à chacun a la
sienne
michel neugnot sur la nouveauté sur
europe c'est difficile pour manuel valls
après avoir été au pouvoir de venir
apporter dans le voit bien par exemple
sur l'idée de la suppression du 49 3
comment appliquer le 49-3 s'en est servi
pour faire passer sa politique puis
après dire qu'on va le supprimer
c'est quand même compliqué je pense
qu'il est serein sur un champ difficile
valls mais c'est toute la logique de la
gauche qui veut gouverner dans le temps
un certain nombre d'avancées ont été
faites
c'est s'appuyer sur ces avancées sont
parle de la loque travail des personnels
d'activité la formation tout au long de
la vie la pénibilité ce qui avait été
fait pour les carrières longues avec des
départs en retraite plus tôt ce sont des
avancées qui ont été faites et manuel
valls qui a connu les difficultés ou
faire ces avancées al interne et à
l'extérieur sait pertinemment ce qui
peut être proposé et ce vers quoi on
veut aller il faut partir des acquis les
améliorer
corriger les trajectoires qui était
mauvaise et sur le 43 il a pris
effectivement la mesure de la division
avec une remarque toute particulière
c'est que 43 été fait par rapport pour
régler les problèmes avec l'opposition
il n'était pas fait pour régler des
problèmes à l'intérieur d'un parti parce
que à l'intérieur loi 10 à l'intérieur
alain régulation dans la majorité
qui le sait à l'intérieur de toute
collectivité
à commencer par la commune la décision
de groupe s'applique à tout le monde
on le sait très bien avec pierre à la
région où nous avons des divergences
entre nous sur certains points mais la
discipline de groupe s'applique toujours
heureux c'est la première fois que
j'utilisais le 40 preuve contre son camp
nou régler des problèmes internes le
feront en effet nouvelles arrivées
répond brigitte vue de répondre parce
que parce qu'il faut passer on va pas
tourner autour du pot se raconter des
bobards calme autour de cette table ici
écoutez pourquoi il ya eu fraude
finalement parce que contrairement à ce
que dit michel parce que nous avons
abandonné participer au même groupe mais
il y avait des discussions il y avait
des arbitrages
il y avait même des votes à certains
moments dans le groupe auquel nous avons
pas retenu autrefois à la région pour ça
sauf que sauf que haut à l'assemblée
nationale et au groupe socialiste
nous n'avons pas eu un seul vote sur
interne sur la doua travail il n'y a
jamais eu d'arbitrage interne ce qui a
permis évidemment fonds à aux
dissensions de se développer et ce qui a
permis aux le moment
venu évidemment à certains de se poser
la question en conscience de savoir si
ce texte était bon pour les salariés ou
pas et sincèrement tel qu'il était
rédigé il ne l'était pas donc il n'était
même pas fidèle au mandat que nous
avions reçues en 2012 de nos électeurs
qui ne nous ont jamais demandé de nier
la représentativité syndicale quand même
dans les négociations possibles filière
par filière
donc voila c'était un dilemme de
moi-même je n'ai vécu je peux je vous le
dis avec difficulté parce que je ne je
suis membre du parti socialiste depuis
de longues années
je veux y être fidèle et c'est par
fidélité justement que j'ai fait ce
choix là ça voulait dire oui moi je
voulais rebondir effectivement je
n'interviendrai pas dans le débat
interne du parti socialiste j'en ai
perdu compétents et puis je n'ai pas
voilà par contre ce qui me paraît
importante vis-à-vis de cette
utilisation du 49 3 c'est ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure c'est de pas tenir
compte de ce qui se passait à
l'extérieur c'est à dire de se dire qu'à
un moment il fallait qu'il y ait un
débat interne sans doute est aussi un
débat externe de se dire quelles sont
les mesures qu'on met en place et tout à
l'heure je parlais de demandes d'audace
je voudrais revenir sur quelque chose
qui est pour moi un manque d'audace qui
était la transition écologique la
transition écologique a été lancé par le
gouvernement
ségolène royal a essayé de mettre des
choses en place on aurait pu être
beaucoup plus ambitieux là dessus et si
on avait été plus ambitieux on aurait
pensé autrement l'économie si on avait
pensé autrement l'économie on n'aurait
peut-être pas mis en place les lois du
travail telles qu'elles ont été mis en
place
logique je pense que c'est un thème de
benoît hamon parce que tout simplement
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit qu'on ne peut
pas faire n'importe quel type d'économie
que la croissance doit être raisonnée et
c'est pour ça que cette croissance
raisonnée elle doit s'appuyer aussi que
sur les ressources naturelles qui sont
pas inépuisables
elle doit aussi s'appuyer sur un autre
type d'emploi c'est de se dire un moment
comme on partage un emploi comme en
forme les gens partagent et de ses
emplois et doux et tout est lié et c'est
lié à l'éducation comme en mai plus de
moyens dans l'éducation demain pour
pouvoir permettre à tout le monde
d'avoir accès en un mot sur la travail
ayant bondi en ligne en mai puis après
on a passé un scénario quand même parce
que les partis politiques sont divers
variés
les syndicats aussi moi je voudrais pas
oublier les syndicats réformistes et
l'accord qu'il y avait avec eux sur la
nécessité de négocier parce que c'est ça
la différence
la durée du temps de travail au plus
près à la base et c'est là dessus que
ladite principe et pour l'avenir et pour
l'avenir
l'idée proposée par manuel valls du
revenu décent est directement issue de
ce syndicat réformiste et c'est un
hommage qu'il fait par cette proposition
à françois chérèque versement serait
apportée au nom du syndicat réformiste
cette idée donc je voudrais pas que on
passe l'ensemble du débat sur le passé
non choix sur l'avenir sur les propos de
danse ont bien croire les débats que ce
qui s'est passé dans la loi travail une
ligne de fracture majeure au ps on est
d'accord il y en a il y en a eu d'autres
est ce que je sais ce que je sais c'est
que il faut partir des acquis de ce
gouvernement qui sont que le saut qui
sont colossaux en matière de défense de
la justice sociale si donner quelques
exemples
il faut s'appuyer sur l'acquis et ne pas
vouloir tout jeter le bébé avec l'eau du
bain repartir à zéro parce que ce dont
nous avons besoin c'est de stabilité
dans les directions qui sont donnés nous
avons remis sur les rails l'économie
la france n'est pas dans l'état où elle
était il ya cinq ans il faut s'appuyer
sur ses acquis et poursuivre écoutez moi
quand j'entends remis sur pieds
l'économie
je comprends que effectivement certain
nombre de gens déjà fort riche en
beaucoup plus d'argent les inégalités se
sont creusées malheureusement nous
n'avons pas résolu la difficulté du
chômage
nous avons quand même un passif de ce
côté là qui est marqué ce qui veut dire
qu'il ya une et au bout du compte une
toute petite relance avec beaucoup de
cadeaux avec le cic avec ses 40
milliards qui ont été accordés aux
entreprises et finalement un medef qui
n'a pas
tenu son engagement on n'a jamais vu le
million d'emplois et finalement avec un
gouvernement qui ne lui a pas réclamé
très fort non plus millions d'emplois il
fallait conditionner ses aides c'est ce
que l'on disait nous ce que l'on dit
encore aujourd'hui
certes utiliser une politique de relance
mais en la conditionnant à la recherche
à la compétitivité à la création
d'emplois ça ça n'est pas venu ensuite
j'entends aussi la théorisation des
fractures au sein des syndicats y aurait
ceux qui sont réforme ou ceux qui ne se
seraient pas il y aurait aussi des bons
socialistes et ceux qui ne seraient pas
de bons socialistes c'est une fin c'est
une façon de théoriser la fracture au
sein de la gauche pour me mener à une
vision que l'on connaît outre-rhin un
jeu met en garde contre ça quand même
parce que moi je ne crois pas aux
gauches irréconciliables je crois au
gauche qui sont capables d'innover de
travail anses en jeu rebondit sur ce que
vous dites à propos d'hier est consigné
réconciliables pour qu'on envisage un
tout petit peu l'après primaire mais
l'après primaire il est en fait déjà à
l'intérieur de de la primaire maintenant
on parle de primaires de la gauche c'est
pas tout à fait vrai puisque des
candidats alors chacun aux extrémités de
l'échiquier de la gauche qui ne sont pas
dans cette primaire c'est quand même
très différent par rapport à 2012
en partie qu'est ce qui va se passer
parce qu'actuellement dans les sondages
le vainqueur potentiel de la primaire il
est jamais au deuxième tour de la
présidentielle moi j'ai envie de vous
demander à quoi ça sert ce que vous êtes
en train de faire
on le voit avec un certain nombre d'élus
qui sont quand même déjà en train de
partir chez d'autres candidats
je prends un exemple pour la bourgogne
jean yves caullet député de l'yonne qui
a fait partie chez emmanuel macron il ya
deux jours donc est ce que les gens vont
en fonction des résultats de la primaire
par exemple si arnaud montebourg
l'emportent est ce que les supporters de
manuel valls pour partir chez emmanuel
macron et al'inverse est ce que les
supporters de benoît hamon ou de
d'arnaud montebourg ils vont partir chez
jean luc mélenchon ce manuel valls gagne
la primaire
grosset vous suivrez quelqu'un d'autre
en fonction des résultats
moi d'abord avant avant tout je pense
qu'on va suivre des projets
effectivement se pliera à la discipline
telle qu'elle a été mis la discipline
mis en place par les primaires telles
qu'elles étaient voulues de soutien
effectivement à celui qui gagnera les
primaires par contre ce qu'il faudra
c'est qu'effectivement le projet qui
soit porté je pense par benoît hamon
puisse être soutenue par les autres et
puis qu'on puisse s'enrichir aussi d'un
certain nombre d'idées de projets émis
par vous me dites pas c'est le cas
échéant oublié de faire un autre choix
je pense que le choix qui a été fait
parce que vous me dire qui est prônée
par benoît hamon c'est de ces deux
suivent c'est de suivre effectivement la
décision et le vote du prêt de après
pardon après paravent les les gens qui
ont voté resteront libres donc il faudra
les séduire il faudra laisser séduire
par un programme ambitieux que c'est
pape voit là et je suis tenir compte
devenir compte des idées et avoir des
idées ambitieuses et de gauche
tout ce je rappellerai la règle tout
simplement tous ceux qui se sont engagés
comme candidat dans les primaires
eux et leurs soutiens se sont engagés
aussi à soutenir le candidat qui sortira
du choix fait par les secours ont
participé à cette élection et du
xinjiang qui ont désiré dictionnaire qui
lui peut dire ce qu'il a envie de dire
la règle des primaires c'est ça ce que
disent tous les leaders qui sont engagés
dans les primaires c'est que pays en
précisant respecteront les règles donc
attention à neuf ne pas créer encore une
fois davantage de confusion alors qu'il
y en a déjà beaucoup à gauche en faisant
croire que ceux qui ont accepté les
règles du jeu seraient les premiers
finalement à s'asseoir dessus reçoit au
soir du produit premier ou de deuxième
tour donc on va rester calme et on va en
vain on va aller dans cette logique-là
alors forcément ce que ce que l'excusé
d'être dit moi je le partage aussi y
aura au moins donné notamment entre les
deux tours une volonté de synthèse qui
est assez traditionnel au sein du parti
socialiste parce qu'il faudra au moins
donné se rapprocher il faut des trains
capacité de constituer une majorité
si manuel valls ne gagne pas la primaire
est ce qu'un certain nombre de gens qui
soutiennent manuel valls pense aussi aux
gens de soutien de vincent peillon qui
pourrait regarder du côté de monaco on
va le dire dans la coulisse en ce moment
là on ne parle que de ça en ce moment
en politique on parle beaucoup de choses
en coulisses avant que les français qui
vont venir voter aux primaires ne se
soit exprimé
je crois que c'était pareil à droite on
parlait beaucoup de choses en coulisses
et le résultat des primaires
notamment du premier tour a remis decker
beaucoup de raisonnement et j'ai le
souvenir de tous les commentateurs qui
le soir et le lendemain 10 ah bah oui ça
ne pouvait pas se passer autrement lors
que trois jours avant lui dise l inverse
nous sommes dans le débat des primaires
je pense que le taux de participation va
être déterminante dans ce qui va se
passer après un candidat quel qu'il soit
et il n'y a pas de petits candidats
parce que chacun est porteur d'un projet
est porteur d'idées différentes se
différenciant des autres mais surtout
d'un corpus commun d'un corpus commun
on l'a bien vu au moment du premier
débat quel quand même un paquet quand
même important donc chacun des candidats
portent quelque chose d'original mais ne
sont pas je vote et je pense je pense
que nous reste une minute je voudrais
que tout le monde nous dit sale sur la
partition le candidat qui sortira ce ne
sera pas la même chose s'il ya cinq cent
mille votants 1 82 million ou plus vous
ferez donc vous respirez tous c'est
effectivement l'objectif que l'on a tous
au niveau de tous les candidats
c'est effectivement qui est le maximum
de votants pour donner le maximum de
crédibilité à condition et il falloir
qu'on soit tous un peu punk chi pour à
laisser du temps à vous et moi j'ai
confiance aussi parce que j'ai vu le
nombre de téléspectateurs qui ont
regardé le premier débat c'est tout à
fait significatives et ça montre qu'il
ya une appétence aujourd'hui
véritablement fait de s'engager là
dessus ça nous fera une bonne conclusion
je pense sur ce train spécial qui leur
impose qu'il faut le respect entre les
candidats a été le cas au premier d'âge
bien j'espère que ça va continuer parce
que vous savez pour être respecté il
faut être respectée
il s'agit de leur plus punchy et du
respect le deuxième débat ce sera ce
soir je crois à 18h30 le suivant jeudi
sur france 2 à 21h merci à tous les
trois et rester avec nous l'a vite et de
francis letellier maintenant dans dix
branches en politique nationale c'est
jean marc ayrault ancien premier
ministre
ministre des affaires étrangères bon
dimanche au revoir lundi vivons bri